- Spécial retour au travail
au menu de ce petit restaurant
asiatique du centre-ville
de Montréal. Un retour
progressif, selon le gérant.
JEFFREY LEM,
gérant, restaurant Fantuan
- C'est difficile.
- Ah oui, comment ça?
- Parce que pas tout le monde
ici maintenant. C'est comme
ci comme ça.
- Ces collègues apprécient
de se voir en personne...
- On ne se voit plus vraimen
au bureau. On essaie de se
Ça fait du bien au moral d'aller
prendre un lunch ensemble.
- ... tant que leur employeur
demeure flexible.
Est-ce que ça vous tenterait
de revenir du lundi au vendredi?
- Je pense pas! La formule
hybride m'a vraime par
exemple, si j'a des rendez-vous
ou quoi que ce soit ou que
je dois visiter des clients,
ciy.
- La Chambre de commerce du
Montréal métropolitain effectue,
depuis la fin du télétravail
obligatoire en juin 2021,
une série de sondages pour
prendre le pouls du retour
au bureau au centre-ville.
Parmi les faits 9XzççXEs
du dernier coup de sonde : en
juin 2021, 28 % des travailleurs
de retour au bureau.
Ils sont maintenant 68 % des
travailleurs à fréquenter leur
bureau à temps plein ou à temps
partiel.
JESSICA BOUCHARD, directrice
principale, relance centre-ville
- On sait que le télétravail
est là pour rester, que le mode
hybride est appréc
et va s'installer dans les
entreprises. Par contre, on peut
dire qu'on a des résultats
qui sont encourageants pourla v.
- Car ceux qui sont de retour
dépensent pratiquement autant
que durant la période
prépandémie.
- Avant la pandémie,
les travailleurs dépensaient
hebdomadairement en moyenne
111 $. Nos résultats démontrenta
baisse de dépense est assez
minime.
- Un des importants employeurs
du secteur, c'est Hydro-Québec,
avec plus de 7000 employés
au coeur de la ville.
La société d'État veut analyser
cette nouvelle donne
dans les prochains mois.
CAROLINE DESROSIERS,
Hydro-Québec
- Donc, on parle en moyenne
de trois jours de télétravail
par semaine. On ne sait pas
comment ça va se passer à longte
plusieurs mois pour voir comment
ça se deroule sur le terrain.
- Le bémol reste le transport
en commun. Le tiers
des travailleurs craint
d'y attraper le virus. Pour
ce qui est des journées les
plus populaires en présence,
les marddis et jeudis
ont la cote. Signe que
le centre-ville retrouve
sa vitalité.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Mon